one bowl of tea on rice pickled plums
slivered nori and leftover chicken all
doused in a piping hot water then
shoveled in was salted kelp that was so
good
all those bowls of tea on rice I'd sneak
into the kitchen to make at the
orphanage damn it I'm gonna die of
hunger
my name is Atsushi and due to
unfortunate circumstances I'm gonna die
from starvation
after being thrown out of the orphanage
we had nothing to eat nor to sleep and
of course I sent to my name and I don't
even have the courage to steal to
survive and so I've arrived at my
current predicament however if I wish to
live I have no choice but to steal and
take from others
get out you good-for-nothing no
orphanage wants someone like you the
world would be a better place if you
just died in a ditch somewhere
[Music]
dying in a ditch let that happen just
you wait I'm gonna live no matter what
right I'm gonna rush the first person
who comes along and then steal
everything they've got
maybe someone going a little slower okay
the next person I don't imagine the
military police carry wallets while
they're in training next time and this
time I really mean it it wasn't quite
what I had in mind I'll let that
wouldn't pass things are you okay I'm
Dave what's that did this guy just see
damn tell me are you the one who
interrupted my submersion
you don't remember yes I saved your life
wait submersion you don't get it I was
trying to kill myself sure I think
everything was going just swimmingly
but you interfered and ruined my
is he scolding me for saving him it's
not all your fault my goal is to commit
a completely clean suicide without
burdening anyone yet I did trouble you
so really the fault lies with me
I should apologize or better still make
it up to you are you by chance hungry
[Music]
how odd I'm also hungry but I'm afraid
the river is taking my wallet you found
me
nice work Nikita nice fork and just who
caused all this work you've suicidal
maniac I've had enough of this
do you realize how often you disrupt my
schedule with your shenanigans I just
had a great idea he's a colleague of
mine from work let's have him treat you
to a meal so tell me what's your name uh
sushi
Nakajima sir very good why don't you
come with me on sushi what would you
like to eat um well if it's not too much
trouble oh come on
there's no need to hold back I'd really
love some tea on rice so what boy on the
brink of starvation wants to eat tea on
rice very well let's have Cooney kita
treats a thirty large bowls of it don't
you get all generous with my money das i
your das i yep that's my name
it's a pleasure to meet you my new
friend
I'm Osamu Dazai
you're unreliable and you're a fool
dassai who says well that's a nice River
and then jumps into it in the middle of
a job now we're late I'll have to revise
our whole schedule here obsessed with
your schedules can this book isn't just
some day planner
this is an ideal this is my sole guide
in life and nowhere in this book is it
written that my coworker should be a
suicidal maniac you really throw
lacombe's wrote before be quiet and know
where my projected expenses is there a
line item for a million bowls of tea on
rice for a snot-nosed kid will grow
wound questions about I'll tell you it
involves the military how are you to
communicating with each other
I strongly suggest you show a little
gratitude after you ate this on my dime
you're a real lifesaver mm-hmm
I came to yokohama straight from the
orphanage I've had nothing to eat nor to
sleep since I thought I'd starve to
death you're from an orphanage I was yes
but they kicked me out sounds like a
real philanthropic organization look
dassai we're not a couple of do-gooders
going around helping hard luck cases
we've got a job to do that reminds me
you said that your current job involves
the military what kind of work do you do
we are private investigators
investigators but we handle more than
lost pets and cheating spouses our
office has uniquely gifted investigators
were the arm detective agency
I've heard of it our Detective Agency
but I thought those were just stories
tales of an agency specializing in cases
that can't be entrusted to the police or
the military an armed force that
straddled the natural and supernatural
worlds that was even war I'd heard that
many members of this elite agency
possess supernatural powers am I in the
presence of two superhumans check out
that support beam up there don't even
think about hanging yourself in his
teahouse of the hanging health technique
what are you talking about you don't
know it's so good for releasing muscle
tension and actually since you mentioned
it today's job doesn't require any
secrecy it's for the government we're
looking for a tiger tiger yes a
ferocious maneater who's recently
appeared in the city well not that we
know for sure it's devoured anyone but
it's ransacked warehouses Eaton farm
animals and caused general chaos the
authorities have received all kinds of
scary reports about it what's wrong
answer she I'll be leaving now
goodbye not so fast
do you know something you're not sharing
with us
don't try there's no way you can stop
that animal really now tell us what you
know about the tiger it's after me it
almost killed me look kid you leave to
pay for the food with your arm or tell
us everything
no no Nikita whenever you ask questions
it quickly deteriorates into an
interrogation
you've been talked to about this let me
try okay now what do you know about this
tiger that tiger kept attacking my
orphanage it ruined our vegetable garden
it decimated our chicken coop and
emptied out our food warehouse I mean no
one died but the orphanage was already
on a tight budget I got kicked out so
they'd have one less mouth to feed I
don't have a home because of that Tiger
place if you just died in a ditch
somewhere
why me we don't need worthless leeches
like you you're not welcome here and
you'll never find a place where you do
belong just go I hope you rot in hell
well that's a tragic tale but back to
the tiger you said it almost killed you
it shows up wherever I go like it's
tracking me hunting me down so it can
pounce and tear me to shreds recently
when I was walking around that tsunami
neighborhood
[Music]
they started seeing you two weeks before
the orphanage expelled me but I've
caught glimpses of it many times since
then my instinct tells me it's come to
the city hunting me when was the last
time you saw the tiger stalking you I
think I saw it in sue to me four days
ago yeah that sounds about right
that makes sense reports of a wild tiger
started coming in two weeks ago and then
it was sighted again in Sioux t'me only
four days ago hmm
hot sushi are you free tonight you being
the man-eaters target presents an
excellent opportunity mm-hmm would you
please help us find the tiger forget it
no way the Nikita please give this to
the agency president but two of you are
going to catch this animal we should
confirm his information first
it'll be fine I'm not doing this okay I
know what you're thinking you're
planning to use me as bait there's no
reward you know no you are not gonna
tempt me with a little money but just so
that I'm totally clear about my decision
how big is the reward for this case
this much
[Music]
dah sigh sorry to interrupt but what are
you reading a good book I'm surprised
you can read when it's this dark I have
excellent nighttime vision besides I've
read it before I know everything that
happens in this book that's funny then
why are you reading it again a good book
is always good do you really think the
tiger will track me down and come here I
know it will but don't worry when it
shows up it'll be no match for me I may
not look tough but I'm with the agency
for good reason I admire your confidence
in fact I'm kind of jealous they called
me a good-for-nothing at the orphanage
as far back as I can remember
and now I don't even know where I'll
sleep tonight or how I'll get through
tomorrow you'll never find a place where
you belong no one would mind if I died
in a ditch somewhere just disappeared
forever yeah maybe I would be better off
getting eaten by a tiger
well then I think it'll be soon I just
heard something back there yes me too
it's probably the tiger toss I not quite
I think the wind just knocks something
down calm down on sushi Tigers don't
suddenly appear out of nowhere how do
you know that for sure because
something's not right with your story
huh just because their finances went
south why would an orphanage banish a
poor helpless child it's not in some
provincial farming village from a bygone
era vanishing one or two mouths to feed
would hardly put a dent in their deficit
it'd make more sense to downsize by
transferring half of the kids to a
different orphanage what are you talking
about does I think about it you came to
the city two weeks ago the tiger also
appeared in the city two weeks ago and
you told us you were in the tsunami war
just four days ago according to reports
the tiger was also cited there four days
ago
remember what kunikida said the arm
Detective Agency is comprised of
individuals with supernatural powers
well-known in fact quite a few people
possess supernatural abilities in this
world some people use their abilities to
achieve great success while others
[Music]
I'm guessing that the orphanage staff
knew who the tiger was but out of fear
they declined to enlighten you you were
the only one in the dark on sushi you
see you also have supernatural powers in
the moonlight you can transform into a
wild beast
an impressive display you could snap a
person's neck you could tear a man's
heart from his chest
come to think of it this isn't a bad way
to meet my dame being eaten by a tiger
even all your strength can't kill me
is no longer human
[Music]
allows me to reverse anyone else's power
it works through a simple touch
[Music]
if you're flirting I'm not interested
there you are Dawson you're late
kunikida
I've captured our predator what do you
mean it's the boy yep he can change into
a deadly tiger oh geez hmm what was with
this note huh huh the tiger will be in
the 15th districts warehouse secure the
perimeter so that it can't escape my
what a lovely and concise note you left
out one vital detail next time you
better tell me what's going on thanks to
you I brought in agents who weren't even
on call first rounds on you
please don't tell me there are no
casualties talk about boring you've
gotten better at solving cases as I but
my logical skills will solve the big
ones he's not dead
what are we gonna do with him when he
wakes up you didn't know he could do
this did he apparently or so it seems
now what da sigh he's been designated as
security for it hmm I've already made my
decision
it called me a good-for-nothing at the
orphanage as far back as I can remember
and now I don't even know where I'll
sleep tonight or how I'll get through
tomorrow no one would mind if I died in
a ditch somewhere just disappear forever
maybe I would be better off getting
eaten buddy typing what are you going to
make him one of us
cool seriously does I you are an idiot
there there my little weird tiger from
up Bob sushi here in a city teeming with
the supernatural in the Detective Agency
bullet eccentrics a strange tales about
to unfold this is only a sign of things
to come
a premonition it starts now
[Music]
how are you not sushi do you remember
anything from when you were transformed
what are you talking about oh look at
that your right hand didn't change back
my right hand
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
Atsushi Nakajima from this day forward
you're going to be one of us you're the
new member of the armed detective agency
and what
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
oh it's been a long time since I've
slept on a futon
I feel reborn hey kid hightail it over
to the agency there's an emergency I'm
an emergency a man's taken a hostage in
our office and he's got a bomb I don't
want to go that sounds dangerous that's
all coming up next time on bingo stray
dogs a certain bomb ability dopo poet
[Music]
[Music]
gee
beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
[Music]